[Música]
llegaron a su casa
así a mullah se escuchaba el ruido de
los abrazos de los pasos y todo empezaba
a llenar su habitación ella sentía que
todo esto le asustaba y decidió
esconderse debajo de la cama después de
que este viento frío que un poquito la
intimidad pasó la niña sale camino
exigir osa mente por el corredor de su
casa y llega hasta un punto en el que
ella creía que nadie la miraba en el que
ya se sentía invisible y comenzó a
observar
qué decide esta gente cómo actuaba
cuáles eran sus gestos y se empezó a
inventar historias hasta que alguien se
movía y ella corría de nuevo a este
lugar seguro que era debajo de su cama
esta niña era yo
a mi madre cuando yo nací y cuando era
una bebé me dijeron tu hija tiene todas
las características para hacer moda o
artista porque yo no balbuceaba no
hablaba me quedaba horas y horas me
termina con una cajita observaba todo y
claro mi mamá de 20 años
se preocupa bien la chiquita
esta niña silenciosa
llegó a cultivar tanto este silencio que
incluso un día ningún mal
pues súper comido
hace sus compras
retorno a la casa empieza a acomodar
todo lo que había comprado y se daba
cuenta que algo le faltaba
le faltaba a su hija se había retirado
el suyo en el súper va corriendo a
rescatar y
mirando en silencio tranquila señora
y así fue como yo fui cultivando o
viviendo con este silencio con esta
soledad
que ahora muchos dicen mentiras y vos
estás en entrevistas estás importadas
haces exhibiciones en muchos países del
mundo
yo soy pintora pero ese es mi secreto
soy completamente introvertida
dicen el 25 por ciento según estudios de
las personas en el mundo son
introvertidos el otros 75 son
extrovertidos pero los estudios también
dicen que nadie es absolutamente una
cosa o la otra
los introvertidos son las personas
normales
nos gusta estar solos disfrutamos de
conocernos nos encanta conversar pero
probablemente nos gusta escoger con
quién cuándo dónde y probablemente ir a
lugares donde muchísima gente como ahora
nos encantan pero después necesitamos
tener un momento a solas
el introvertido no es tímido el
introvertido no es un antisocial no
somos raritos aunque a veces parecemos
simplemente somos un poquito más calmos
analíticos reflexivos incluso a veces
nos tildan de flojos dispersos
le damos mucha importancia al
pensamiento
al mirar las cosas y ya poder responder
a la vida de una manera más pausada
y yo soy un poquito eso y un poco más de
todo
en el proceso creativo en el proceso de
lo que yo hago en mi trabajo he
aprendido que este es perfecto pero acá
está cualidad distinta que es ser
introvertida me ayude a observar
observar muchísimo quizás poder ver de
manera distinta como otras personas
miran
reflexionar como les decía antes pero
también y sobre todo y creo que este es
el mensaje importante a valorar en el
proceso así como hay un proceso creativo
yo creo tenazmente el éxito es el éxito
que se ve en instagram en facebook o en
cualquier otro lugar visible es el
resultado de un caminar de un paso a
paso de un día a día así como el proceso
creativo empieza con un concepto y va
atravesando muchas etapas la vida es
igual y nosotros debemos aprender a
disfrutar
este día a día del proceso y aprender a
resignificar la palabra éxito
porque una mujer es exitosa
este probablemente trabaja cada día para
lograr lo que quiere
en este proceso
personalmente incluye muchísimos
momentos de soledad
momentos de introspección para conocerme
verdaderamente y saber qué es lo que
quiero para que lo quiero hacer porque
este ímpetu ven hacer tantas cosas a la
vez
todos ustedes yo creo que tienen s
esa cualidad de pensar de hacer de que
la gente cree que está en un 4 y están
en otro
entonces no hay aquí diferencias si
somos introvertida si son más divertidas
la cosa es ser como queremos ser
y en este caminar hay otro estudio que
dice que
de las personas que se hacen una lista
al inicio del año con todo lo que
quieren hacer con todos los objetivos
que quieren lograr sólo el 8 por ciento
a fin de año consigue haberte quedado la
mayoría de las de los objetivos de esa
lista
y esto se debe a que muy poca gente
escribe sus objetivos
tal cual muy poca gente se plantea
objetivos cortitos a corto plazo reales
y eso no significa que les diga chicas
no piensen en grande por supuesto que
hay que pensar en grande pero nosotros
mujeres somos las primeras en jugarlos
mirar a la otra y criticar en pensar que
no somos suficientes cuando el de
ustedes creen o mientras están
conduciendo las que tienen hijos
llevándolos de un lugar a otro están
pensando en todo lo que tienen que hacer
le dicen a su hijo
a cualquier cosa que les está diciendo y
encima de eso al final del día creen que
no lo hicieron bien
entonces creen que nunca lo van a lograr
y es mentira
lo logramos cada día lo logramos todos
los días en cada paso
en este caminar en este descubrirnos en
nuestras debilidades
descubrirnos en nuestras fortalezas
encontrar y entender que la vida es esto
a paso como un proceso entendiendo que
cada día es una victoria que somos no
les voy a contar un cuento motivacional
repetidos así que vamos mujeres podemos
porque podemos por supuesto que sí pero
entender de verdad
mujeres que somos capaces de lograr lo
que nos da la gana
pero así de verdad va a hacer que
nuestra vida un clima y entender también
que en este ponernos objetivos y caminar
hacia ellos encontraremos momentos de
alta felicidad
encontraremos también que lo que nos
hemos planteado no siempre nos va a
salir como lo hemos propuesto
y que la clave está en aprender
de esos errores y seguir y como yo
siempre repito y digo en hacer la cosa
es hacer la cosa es seguir haciendo
y nunca pensar que no vamos a ser
capaces de lograrlo
yo les quiero compartir que en este mi
oficio de la del arte de hacer de
producir de estar en la pantalla de
estar ahí públicamente
a la vista de todos este miedo eléctrico
o mi secretito de ser introvertida me
gusta tanto antes era una cosa que
cargaba y no me gustaba pero lo disfruto
tanto porque he descubierto en eso he
descubierto en mí
que todo lo que yo me propongo
no puedo conseguir que el camino que se
puede mover que tener la capacidad de
ser flexible entonces hoy esta noche sin
mucho más que decirles o con mucho que
quiero también comentarles las desafío a
que lleguen a su casa hoy o mañana
y le da flojera
se sienten
se paren caminen es lo que quieren y se
empiecen a mirar
quién soy
pero quién soy de ver
no podemos mentir a nadie o si le
podemos mentir a todos nosotros quién
soy que quiero
que hicieron de verdad y puedo querer
cosas muy distintas a lo que la gente
espera de mí y está bien que hago para
lograr esto para que quiero hacer lo que
me propongo hacer y respondiendo hacer
todo este tipo
cuestiones
y descubrir en ustedes la maravillosa o
el maravilloso poder de transformar
todas las debilidades en fortalezas hoy
día
este es lo que yo les quiero transmitir
tomemos el coraje seamos capaces de
mirarnos de descubrirnos de
confrontarnos porque solamente podemos
ser lo que somos por supuesto que
podemos mejorar podemos cambiar podemos
crecer pero somos lo que somos
y el resto del mundo es lo que es y una
vez entendiendo esto vamos a tener la
libertad la capacidad la fuerza nos va a
dar la gana de hacer lo que queramos
hacer
[Música]